okay um so i have a question for the
ladies she looked directly at me
do you think that
who gets wifed up faster hoes or proots
wait explain
like a girl a girl that like waits or a
girl that sleeps with a guy right away
whoa who do you think it gets wifed up
faster
it really is a sticky one that's a good
question
someone that get um
a food someone awaits you think so yeah
i believe so because i feel like if
you're able
kind of does depend on the vibe but if
you're able to just like
slang it out so soon so quickly he might
not take you as seriously as someone
that's like more patient and would get
to know him
and kind of understand him better really
yeah let's hear from the guys i disagree
totally okay yeah you'd rather have
someone that would just no no no
you don't have to slang it out no but
that was but no but it's like
there's a difference between that let's
say you make someone wait for a month
but whilst you're making me wait for a
month let's say i may just like lose
interest in but you're making moves
towards like but she's just holding off
i'm just saying that
like not me but just like people
people they might like
lose interest in that because is that
all that like chasing and stuff like
that bro not everyone wants to do the
chasing stuff for so long but i mean you
can you chase say you chase you get it
what now yeah imagine you chase for
imagining chase for a month and it's
dead bro oh
okay and then what if you chase for a
month and it's good then you're chilling
but we could have been good
the next day
um we could be like all right cool maybe
we're not you know this is what 29 days
so it's basically it's based on the
90-day rule
i don't know that's a bit of a sticky
one see because
on one hand i feel like guys do value
some sort of purity right and it's
biologically wired so they can't really
get rid of it but any guy like that
finds out his girl slept with a hundred
people probably wants to throw up
yeah yeah
thank you i'll get a heart you know i'll
never wife you if you have hundred
bodies
yeah but then that means she'll be
slanging it out every first date she's
on do you get what i'm saying
you see first date i can't like yeah
don't experiment that's what i'm saying
it has to you have to
you know i mean run a little bit and
you know flex a little bit but you can't
just you know because then you think our
next man could have had it easy like
that yeah so
it's just i guess there is a balance in
it because then you could go on a lit
first date and you guys could have sex
and then it could even be even better
but because you know the person you guys
are on the same vibe you kind of can
move forward from that but whereas like
do you know what i mean slang it out and
then you're done with that
yeah i feel like i feel like there is a
balance like
wait but don't slang out too early to
get yeah but if you're to make them wait
don't make them wait too long that just
depends on who the guy is there's some
guys that don't mind they can wait till
marriage there's some guys
i don't know but bro let's be rude there
are actually out there
there are guys
[Laughter]
now but there are actually some guys
that can we would want to wait but that
this depends on them
yeah that's the thing that just has to
be
i feel like that just has to be a
balance between dinner
are you waiting until you're married
okay
i thought you you said you said okay
she said no
i like to have a little bit of fun you
know what i mean i'm here for
in the comments it says it's not
biologically wired it is biologically
wired because over in history men have
to ensure paternity
so and the reason men prefer like a
lower body count is because historically
they had to ensure paternity
so um they had to make sure that they
weren't passing on resources to a kid
that wasn't theirs
because birth control changed the game
but that wasn't around historically and
even now there's some studies that say
up to like 20 of men are raising a kid
that's not theirs
is crazy so would you guys do that
he's a kid that's not mine yeah
you'll fall in love with it yeah that's
hard it depends on what that sort of
situation with the goal like if i'm with
that it's not even just that it's not
even just if you're with them
if you've been with her
think about it think about it think
about it so so she told me she's
pregnant like two months pregnant
so for that seven months before the
baby's born you've
grown to like adapt to like becoming a
man and then
you could be with a kid like four months
five months could be the first day you
love that baby
like find out that's not yours
your love for the baby is not going to
like change it's going to change for the
girl you're going to hate the girl yeah
resentment every time you look at the
baby you could just be like damn
like
i can't control it have you not seen
them like judge shows where
they're having like them like they have
the test or you're the father you're not
the father
and you see that they're like the men
just break down in tears
it hurts it bro
if she's had the kid already and
would you guys do it then
you have to collect for the right i mean
for the right but the kid has to be
young though if you're 15 in that corner
oh my gosh
you know what's crazy about that like
the perception will probably change
like you know if you're like 40 50
unless you're single
bro a lot of women are gonna come
in contact with may have a kid bro and
they're gonna be 15 16 17 18
then it will change bro i mean yeah when
i get to that point it would change 15
hours loose bro
come on imagine i'm trying to imagine
trying to say something you're not my
dad oh
no
no but it's like when they're younger
yeah it'll be less it'll be a less
likely thing that they will say that
because yeah because they're young in it
that's probably
the first exactly
but they know that there's a dad there
now someone's coming to now come like
take over
and then you've raised your voice at me
like are you my dad no you are you bro